a rented car can also pick up your data
via USB to do his experiment blogger
Lyon sigv connected the phone to the
rented car infotainment system via USB
port all the contacts messages of
previous passengers were waiting for him
there Lon went to Google found all of
the data of our driver Jordan In the
Flesh having your phone number and name
attackers can do terrible things they
may demand payment for you for allegedly
damaging their car our Jordan fell for
such a trick and entered the data until
Lyon stopped the call himself anyone can
fall for this trick since the car renter
has information about the car model its
color agency and driver's name so here
are the tips to save yourself one if you
want to charge your phone use the
cigarette light support with one of
those dongles or use a USB cable with no
data ability two don't accept the
prompts that pop up on your phone when
you connect to the infotainment system
use only GPS or music and three don't
use Bluetooth or your data will
automatically syn